aquí tengo un polinomio b de x y px está
expresado como un polinomio de cuarto
grado que multiplica a 3 x menos 8
elevado al cuadrado y bueno de hecho al
elevar esto al cuadrado me va a quedar 9
x cuadrada más un montón de cosas y
luego al multiplicarlo por un polinomio
de cuarto grado nos dará un polinomio de
sexto grado ahora bien esta vez nuestro
objetivo va a ser encontrar los valores
de x que hagan
pd x p de x igual a cero es decir voy a
encontrar las raíces o los ceros de este
polinomio y en particular nos vamos a
enfocar a las raíces cuando 0 2 reales
las raíces reales de este polinomio y
como siempre te invito a que intente
resolver esto y después lo vamos a hacer
juntos
ok vamos a resolverlo entonces para
resolver p de x 0 lo que quiero hacer es
toda esta expresión igual a 0 y así
encontrar los valores de x que harán que
este polinomio sea igual a 0
y para hacerlo la mejor manera que se me
ocurre es factorizar voy a intentar
factorizar lo más que pueda y después
ver si lo puedo escribir como el
producto de un montón de expresiones
igualadas a cero porque recuerda si el
producto de un montón de cosas es igual
a cero entonces cuando cualquiera de los
productos es igual a cero toda la
expresión será igual a cero pero bueno
ya llegaremos para ella y lo bueno de
aquí es que tenemos a 3 menos 8 esto
elevado al cuadrado ya factorizar así
que voy a intentar factorizar todo lo
demás por agrupación se me ocurre
intentar factorizar lo por agrupación
así que déjame agrupar estos dos
primeros términos en estos dos primeros
términos y después voy a agrupar se me
ocurren los otros dos
y bueno con esto vamos a hacer la
factorización por agrupación porque
recuerdan factorizar por agrupación es
lo mismo que hacer lo inverso de la
propiedad distributiva dos veces
entonces para estos dos primeros
términos que me va a quedar bueno se me
ocurre que de aquí puedo factorizar
bueno lo más que puedo actualizar es x
cúbica
así que me va a quedar x kubica que va a
multiplicar a bueno primero tengo a 3x y
después tengo menos 8 de lugo y observa
aquí tengo un 3x menos 8 y por aquí
también tengo 3x menos 8 creo que eso
nos va a servir bastante muy bien ahora
vamos a hacer lo mismo con estos de
color rosa que tenemos por aquí y lo más
que puedo factorizar de ellos dos bueno
es un 55 que va a multiplicar aquí en 5
que multiplica a 3
y 5 que multiplica a 8 negativo de lujo
entonces mira por aquí también tengo 3 x
menos 8 y todo esto está adentro de un
paréntesis déjame ponerlo adentro de un
paréntesis que a su vez multiplica a 3 x
menos 8 al cuadrado 3 x menos 8 esto a
su vez elevado al cuadrado y bueno todo
esto es igual a cero así que déjame
ponerlo esto es igual a cero ahora
observa que tengo este 3 x menos ocho
este de aquí como factor común entonces
qué te parece si lo factor izamos
también me quedaría 3x déjame ponerlo
así 3
x menos 8 que va a multiplicar aquí el
bueno en primer lugar multiplica a x
ubican a este de aquí así que déjame
ponerlo así va a multiplicar a x cúbica
y después va a multiplicar a este 5 que
tengo aquí a este 5 que tengo aquí
entonces x cúbica más 5 déjame cerrar mi
paréntesis y esto a su vez multiplica a
3x menos 8 esto elevado al cuadrado y
bueno claro esto es igual a 0 y si
sientes que lo que hice aquí fue algo de
vudú solo date cuenta que tengo aquí dos
veces 3x menos 8 entonces los saco como
factor común
voy a sacar este 3 x 8 como factor común
como factor común lo único que estoy
haciendo es hacer lo inverso de la
propiedad distributiva y entonces al
sacarlo como factor común
quedo con este término de 3x kubica
porque está multiplicando a 3 x menos 8
y también me quedo con este término de
más 5 porque observa que está
multiplicando también a 3x menos 8
espero esté más claro ahora tengo 3x
menos 8 que multiplica a x cúbica 5 que
a su vez multiplica a 3x menos 8 elevado
al cuadrado así que puedo multiplicar
estos 23 x menos 8 puede multiplicar
este por este y que me quedaría bueno me
va a quedar 3x menos 8 esto elevado
ahora a la tercera potencia estoy
multiplicando estos dos y bueno esto a
su vez que multiplica a este de aquí a
este de aquí que multiplica a x cúbica
más
y bueno esto es igual a 0 es igual a 0
ahora para que esto sea igual a 0 tiene
que pasar lo siguiente o esta expresión
de aquí es igual a 0 o esta expresión de
aquí es igual a 0 déjame ponerlo o 3 x 3
x menos 8 esto elevado al cubo es igual
a cero o bueno en su caso déjame ponerlo
así o equis cúbica x cúbica más 5 esto
es igual a cero entonces primero
pensemos qué pasa cuando hacemos 3x
menos 8 al cubo igual a cero si esto es
igual a cero que va a pasar
bueno esto nos dice que 3 x 3 x menos 8
debe de ser igual a 0 y si 3 x menos 8
es igual a 0 entonces 3x tiene que ser
igual a 8 y déjame bajar un poco en la
pantalla
y esto nos está diciendo que si
dividimos todo entre 3 dividimos todo
entre 3 todo entre 3 x tiene que tomar
el valor de 8 tercios para que este
polinomio se haga 0
esta es una raíz si tú pones aquí x
igual a 8 tercios bueno pues esto se
hace 0 y 0 por lo que sea va a ser cero
estás de acuerdo entonces esta es una de
nuestras raíces reales de lujo ahora
vamos a ver qué pasa con la otra
posibilidad tengo x cúbica más 5 igual a
cero bueno esto quiere decir que x
cúbica tiene que ser igual a menos 5 muy
bien y bueno esto quiere decir que x
tiene que ser igual a la raíz cúbica
la raíz cúbica de menos 5 y seguramente
en este momento te puedes preguntar hoy
existe una raíz cúbica negativa la
respuesta es que si la raíz cúbica de
menos 1 es menos 1 o la raíz cúbica de
menos 8 es menos
así que esta raíz cúbica que tengo aquí
va a ser un número negativo y no un
número imaginario por lo tanto esta
también es una raíz de nuestro polinomio
que es real si tú puedes el valor aquí
de la raíz cúbica de menos 5 vas a hacer
este polinomio igual a 0 y si tú
quisieras saber cuánto es la raíz cúbica
de menos 5 bueno podemos hacerlo por
aquí déjame sacar mi calculadora por acá
y bueno si yo quiero la raíz cúbica de
menos 5 voy a obtener primero en la raíz
cúbica de 5 lo cual es déjame ponerlo
así 5 elevado a la potencia un tercio
muy bien esto me va a dar 1.7 0 99 y
bueno si yo quisiera la raíz cúbica de
menos 5 tendré que poner un signo
negativo aquí es decir la raíz cúbica de
menos 5 es menos 1.7 1 aproximadamente
déjame escribirlo esto va a ser
aproximadamente
x es aproximadamente 1.7 1 negativo de
lugo esta sería mi raíz cúbica
aproximada así que tenemos dos raíces
reales dos raíces reales de este
polinomio dos ceros reales para este
polinomio y estos serán los lugares
donde vamos a interceptar al eje x estas
son las dos intersecciones con el eje x
y ya está nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo